Through the same X-ray, cardio megalene was shown. I presume this is from the chemo or the Hashimoto's. Is this something that could heal or is it's a permanent issue?
So cardio megalene is in enlarged heart. And I don't think it was from the chemo nor do I believe it was from the Hashimoto's cardio megalene is extremely common.
It's common with everybody, but it's more common with people that were athletes during their growing part of their life. So they were junior high and high school athletes college athletes.
cardio megalene is extremely common. So are there dangers with cardio megalene? Yes and no. For the most part, no, though in a large heart can cause some issues with valve closures. So you can get some reflux into the ventricles and things with, you know, valves not closing completely.
Because the growth of the valve may not have, have kept up with the growth of the muscle tissue of the heart.
So that can be an issue. So these people can have issues with, you know, skipped heartbeats, irregular heartbeats.
And it and just, you know, have to be aware that they could have, you know, infections of valves if there's regurgitation into of a valve.
But for the most part, if it's found incidentally on an x-ray unless it's a abnormally gross cardio megalene, it's typically just commented on and nothing is typically done about it.
Sometimes people will be put on beta blockers if they have extremely irregular heartbeats that goes along with it.
But that's not that common for that to have for that to be an issue.
Is it something that can heal? No, not really. Is it a permanent issue? Yeah, probably.
It's not something that you would necessarily be concerned with even. So I have cardio megalene from, you know, being an athlete in junior high in high school.
Most people that were athletes that really, you know, I was a runner. So, you know, push myself real hard. That's pretty common. Probably everybody in my track team. You know, so it's, I have issues.
I have irregular heartbeats if you put a heart monitor on me. It's, it's kind of weird. But I don't think it's really an issue.